- I'm starting my vlog today, solo.
8:58 in the morning.
Had somebody cancel so,
me and Iris are on different schedules.
Pullin' up to the office, good day.
Got Nightline following me around today.
So I'm excited about that, so
some of your grandparents and parents
are gonna check that out
on the 'television'.
You'll see that online.
I will chop it up.
Super excited, all great stuff.
Focused, VaynerMedia.
Just the Vayner X family, PureWow
all that is going extremely well.
Tons of strategies for
2018 being implemented,
super excited for Agent 2021 our first
owned and operated conference
in Miami next week.
That should be great and
obviously the book is
right upon us, obviously.
Super excited about 'Crushing It'.
It's doing extremely well in sales
which I appreciate.
YouTube, YouTube, YouTube
if you have not pre-ordered it,
now is the time.
Don't break my heart.
(hip hop music)
You know,
what a lot of people
don't understand about
raising capital is
you just need somebody to say yes.
It's not about, here's how you do it.
You
There's seven people
running around right now
that love coffee and tattoo
and there's a tattoo artist who's
grandfather left him or her
a million dollars and they're trying to
figure out where to spend it.
Those people exist.
Like, you're not gonna go to Silicon
The reason everyone's losing is
they want to go to Silicon
Valley and talk to bankers
and math kids, and they
run you through the ringer
and it's a waste of time.
You need to find entrepreneurial money
who believe in you.
You need to go find somebody
who sold their agency
and has $12 million dollars now
and is looking to do something
and it's like, oh I understand Mike and
I love skateboarding and tattoos and
I love,
do you understand?
So, I'm giving you a piece of advice that
people are just not understanding.
That's the game.
You don't go to somebody
who's gonna say no.
And that's what every artist
every creative entrepreneur
is doing right now
and it's a complete waste of time.
Raising capital, it's
so many of you have gotten caught in this
bullshit venture capital
and banking world.
When you need money,
you gotta be willing to
get it in any shape or form
as long as it's clean money
and as long as the person
you're getting from isn't
going to put you emotionally
in a bad place, right?
You don't want to get money from your aunt
who's then gonna
text you 15 times a day and say
you suck!
You know,
that brings in too much family dynamics
but nonetheless,
what I mean by that is
everybody's trying to fit into the mold of
how to sell to a venture capitalist,
when that's like a moonshot.
Instead of trying to find
high net worth individuals
who believe in your vision like
I've never made
I've written
millions of dollars in
checks in my career.
And it's never been because of the math
and then other people
have never written a check
that hasn't been about the math
and neither is right or wrong.
It's about styles and so
but too many of you have
no chance of getting
silicon valley venture capital firm
to write you a check.
And all you do is you
sit and you make excuses,
'I didn't go to a good college' or
'I don't look the part' or
'They don't invest in minorities'
or whatever you may come up with
instead of going to who
will give you money.
Find who will give you money.
High net worth individuals who are
creative and open minded.
Find them.
I'm super okay.
(laughs)
- [Female] And you've time to speak with
Jarvis.
- Looking forward to it.
- [Female] In this office later.
- [Female] Cool.
- Hey!
- Let's do it.
So these ladies flew from Australia.
- Thank you.
- For you!
What kind of teenage were you?
- I was a great teenager.
My mom
I'm writing a book called
Perfectly Parented.
So it's interesting to hear what you guys
- [Both] Wow!
- This is awesome!
- So I'm writing a book
called Perfectly Parented.
And it's the perspective
of a kid who feels
his parents perfectly parented him.
My mom and dad
so I never
did any, I mean I did nothing
wrong except get bad grades.
So I never disrespected anybody,
I never did cliche
drugs and alcohol stuff.
I was the nicest kid,
I was friends with
everybody in my high school,
I worked every minute.
I went to like seven high
school parties in my life.
I just worked, I helped around the house
'cause I was the oldest.
I was a ridiculously good kid, yet
I wasn't like a square, meaning
I had fun, I enjoyed it,
my high school years were very simple.
I worked every minute,
which was the happiest moments of my time
whether it was doing baseball card shows,
selling at flea markets or
working at my dad's liquor store.
Or, I
was in school being miserable.
I didn't play sports, I
played tennis for two years
but I barely played sports.
I didn't chase girls for the most part,
I just was very focused
on being an entrepreneur
from a very young age,
and I was obsessed with
not making my mom upset.
- I love it.
(laughs)
Saying as I'm a mom.
- It's just true.
Like, I
my mom guilted me into
being a great child,
and a great teenager and
I think that's what I do
to my employees.
- How, how?
- By providing so much love and support
that the fear is letting them down.
Guilting.
Iris was going to leave after working
for a year, that was her plan.
That was her thoughts.
But she's still here because
it's better to be here
than it's not to be here.
- Well, a lot of teenagers
actually disconnect
from their parents.
- Because their parents are screwing up!
Their parents are doing the wrong thing.
Their parents care about
themselves, not their kids.
Parents are struggling out there because
they're insecure, and they're
parenting their children
based on the judgment of other parents
not based on the putting their kids in the
position to succeed.
(reflective piano)
- I understand that.
Get me on the phone with
them for five minutes.
- I got to figure it out, anyways
when we started basically
a digital agency
- [Gary V] When was that?
- This is like late
middle of 2016.
- [Gary V] 'kay.
- And, I mean it's just
straight to the fire.
- [Gary V] Yep.
- And I had no problem with that,
like that's where I think I thrive.
Took us a little bit of time to figure out
what our niche was
and then once we figure that out and
it's been a really, it's
been incredible like
I have, we have a team of six.
Space in the city, I mean, typical stuff.
Trying to make it happen
- [Gary V] Yep, yep.
- With what we can.
I guess one of the main things that I'm
running up against now is like
I need to scale.
I need a couple more people.
I need to be able to do
certain things that I'm doing.
- [Gary V] There's only
two ways to do that.
It's a chicken and egg game.
You either go out and get
enough business that
allows you to afford it,
or you convince people
to work for you for free,
because you know that
you're a good enough guy
that when you can make it whole,
you will.
- [Man] Okay, that makes sense.
- But there's a ton of
22 year old you and me
and Boyds and Iris's.
There's a lot of them.
There's just a lot of kids who are 22
who want to fuck with you,
you just have to create the net.
So, you have to start.
People are scared to ask
for people to work for free.
But you have to find
two people who are worth
a year that are willing
to work for $14 an hour.
'Cause you might have to pay minimum wage,
I don't know what the rules are.
- [Man] I for sure am scared to ask people
to work for free.
- Here's why.
Let me tell you,
I know, I know.
Let me tell you the secret
of why I fuck with it.
Because I'm gonna pay them back more.
And I know I'm capable of.
And I know that if I wasn't capable of,
I would die to the end.
If this went bankrupt because
there was fraud going on,
and I owed a lot, six of them dollars,
well that's what I would work on
until I would start up again.
The biggest reason people
are scared to ask people
to work for free is they think
it's doing the wrong thing
and I think it's doing the right thing.
There's a lot of street kids
who are not going to NYU,
who are going to a community college that
no agency wants to hire 'cause they're
hiring from better schools
who you'll fuck with
and they'll fuck with you.
You might have to kiss some frogs
when you get free you get
what you pay for sometimes.
But, I
spoke for free.
I do stuff for free.
I'm doing stuff for free, constantly.
I'm doing this meeting!
The fuck is this meeting for me?
- [Man] Yeah, that's
what I'm wondering too.
- Well I'm
(laughs)
this is my version of
working for free!
- I understand.
- People, when I talk
about working for free,
people love to come out
and fuckin' kill me.
I know what you guys are thinkin'!
They're just not as smart.
There's two people on earth right now
who can be a designer or an account person
or a media planner or
whatever the fuck you do,
who are willing to work for you,
for $15 because you told them at
a pop-up salad QSR for an hour that
you got them.
- Right.
- And they're gonna say,
you're brown like me too.
It's always the ones that look like you.
You know,
kids that went to Yale, and went to MBAs
they don't fuck with me.
- Which is cool.
- Until they break at 29.
Then they find me.
- So to give you a little bit
of background about myself
and how I got started,
I got into fitness in 2012,
kind of accidentally.
I was on my own journey,
experiencing health problems,
my journey is very much in fitness
more about the health side of things.
- Yep.
- And I joined Instagram
to motivate myself,
we were actually living
in China at the time.
And being alone on that journey
- Sure.
- Instagram was my way to
connect and communicate
- Of course, of course.
- With people
- Especially back home, right?
- Yeah, and
since that was really at
the beginning of Instagram
I started organically growing a page
just by connecting with people
- I know enough about your story
like I know enough about
that era of Instagram
to know that you were on
that wave, I remember.
- Yeah.
Okay, so fast forward to today,
pretty much I built this
brand kind of on accident
but it's been amazing.
Something that I'm passionate about
and I'm able to connect with people on and
I launched the app, December 17th.
So it's been just a few weeks
and so
the launch was great, my community
kind of just freaked out, exploded
and they're loving it.
I would just say that,
where we're at now is
we're a pretty small team.
We're a team of like, five.
And the demand is exceeding
our potential as a small team.
- Well let me give you a
first big piece of advice.
Try to keep less money.
- Keep less money.
(laughs)
- Of course.
- Invest more in the company.
- 100 percent.
Unless you're retiring next year,
the biggest mistake that
people that go through
what you're going through right now make
is they're trying to maximize profit
to buy the things that
the two of you want.
- Yeah.
Right.
- So they're willing to not
hire three more teammates
and invest in the business,
because they want an extra
vacation or a bigger bedroom
or three more handbags.
I mean that's real!
The biggest first piece
of advice I would make
is the following.
There are, Ming, right?
- Minh.
- Minh, spell it?
- M-i-n-h
- There are seven
thousand Minhs right now.
Do you know how pumped Minh is too?
(laughs)
You have to understand how
this is all playing out.
Minh is a young woman, Alex
Iris
There are people who are under 25
Alex is way over 25.
(laughs)
You are?
Wow, you look great.
But there's a lot of people right now,
there's an unbelievable amount of
talented 22 to 24 year olds,
who look up to you,
who are willing to work for very little.
You need to build out your team,
and take it out of your short term pocket
to create long term success.
I get
40 emails a week, minimally of
I have an MBA,
I've been running a
business for four years,
I've made, forget about learned.
I've made more money
in the last six months
watching your vlog and
listening to your podcast
than I did the last six years
with all that background.
Because you have to understand,
this is of the moment.
The reason they're so
do you understand that
all of you in this room
don't realize how smart you are?
'Cause you're in your own bubble.
I mean this!
You're in the forefront of something,
which then means you don't understand
because then you're only
surrounding yourself with
other people that are
doing the same thing.
99 percent of the people
don't believe what's going on
in Crushing It.
And when I wrote the first one,
the thought of making money
on YouTube or social media
was absurd!
I mean, go read the first Amazon comments
of my first book, nine years ago.
So you've already got the mentality,
now let me give you the practicality.
Get four people on your team
for the cost of what you
probably allocated for one.
An enormous amount of
22 year olds right now
and more next year because
they're getting affected
in the teenage years,
every year more
dream job in life is to
either be an influencer,
or work for one.
That's just real!
- For better or for worse, yeah.
We're excited to read the book!
- Thank you, yes!
Yes enjoy!
- Yeah, that's my MBA right there.
- I love it.
I think you'll really like it.
I hope there's one or two
little nuggets that can
you're so in it that it
will come natural but
I really actually wrote
it for people like you.
There was like four to seven
things that are in there
that I'm like, okay this
is the best shit I know
that I think maybe even
for the people that know
they may not know.
- [Anna] Awesome.
- Thank you.
- Cool.
- [Anna] Thank you again.
- Thank you guys, take care, bye bye.
The reason this is intriguing is that
the streets will fuck with it,
and so it's got bigger upside.
This is why I'm gonna go to the point that
I want to make, which is,
when I think about businesses like this,
the biggest thing that I'm gonna give you
a huge piece of recommendation.
You don't want to be at the
mercy of these fuckin' logos.
Got it?
- You don't think you
got Penn State, Michigan,
Indiana
- Nope!
- You got 100
- I know exactly what you're gonna say.
Here's the good news, no.
Here's why.
You don't have the leverage.
I'm gonna say it again,
It's way better if you guys
design something with a logo
that was yours,
and people started coming to you.
Your patent's not gonna
hold, your brand will.
- Let me ask you a question.
Luis Vuitton is not a one
single product company.
- It started as one.
- It did, but is that what
you're saying this could be?
- Period.
- Where we're doing more
things than just the hood?
- That's how it always works.
- Okay.
- Well just, you did say
- [Gary V] What do you think
Under Armour started as?
What do you think Nike started as?
Every brand we're about to say
started as a single product company.
- Your fifth business book
just came out.
- Yes.
- It will have just come out
at the time of this interview.
(light jazzy music)
- Talks for something dealing with TV.
- You're having a moment.
- Yes.
Yes.
And I'm trying to see
where the right place is
to grab it, because I love what I do.
I absolutely love what I do.
I love the classroom, I
love working with kids.
But I'm
- Do you understand that
you have a moment right now
and you can always go
back to the classroom
and maybe never have a
moment like this again?
Have you thought about that?
Because a lot of times I
think people think about
selling out or changing their lives.
But what I love about being a teacher
in many other things that people do,
I always remind people,
just do me one favor.
Know what you can come back to
and what you can't come back to.
- I definitely got a great unit, man,
I couldn't ask for more.
- Then you should go for it.
When shit's good, you go in the offense.
You're crippled by opportunity,
my answer is, if you've
got it good at home
and she's supporting you
and the little one's not going to remember
any of this anyway
(laughs)
then go.
Take your moment.
- This is the stuff that
I'm telling my kids!
(laughs)
Forward, like take what is there.
Take this opportunity.
This is what I'm
- It's easier to give
advice than to take it.
Which is why I think I've popped because
I think I only give advice
that I already took,
so nobody can call me
on the vulnerability.
I'm a practitioner of all my thesis.
Casey actually, you know what?
Fuckin' Casey.
Casey Neistat's a fuckin' beast.
What he said, where is he?
'The name Gary V has
become synonymous with
motivating an entire generation.
No one understands the
power of social media
better than Gary, because
none of what he preaches
is theory.
It's an understanding born from his deep
expertise in business and life.'
What Casey understood about
me in his quote for this book
is, I'm not guessing.
I would have regretted if
I didn't take my moment
back in 2006 when I'm like,
wait a minute, am I a wine merchant
or am I a anthropology-like digital
what am I?
- Right.
- I could
I never knew the word
I wasn't a good student so I
didn't know all these words.
They came to me later.
But I failed forward, I tasted,
and most of all, I just
did not worry about
what anybody else thought.
Go do your thing.
- I'm ready to, man.
- Just go do it.
- I'm really really serious.
- Honestly just go very hard.
- Yeah.
- Say yes to everything.
- Word.
- Until you can't fuckin' breathe.
- I'm ready for 'em and you know,
it's funny, this was the year I said,
at school I was like,
this was gonna be my year
to say no.
And watch all the things
that I'm accepting,
but I realized, like you're saying,
the more important focus is that yes.
And where I'm putting those yes's.
- Dude, you know what's up?
When you say yes,
and you can't breathe
anymore because you're
saying yes to everything,
the yes's are giving you more oxygen!
- Yeah
It's the truth.
- It's the truth.
- Thank you for this, man.
- Talk to you soon.
- Can't say it enough,
thank you so much.
- Stay well.
- Peace, y'all.
(reflective piano music)
- The day's been fuckin' crazy.
Straight fuckin' crazy.
Right?
- [Female] Yeah.
- Even by our standards.
- Okay, you ready?
Do you think that there's destiny in life?
- I think DNA is a big fuckin' deal.
And I think has a whole lot to do with
how things play out.
And I think there's certain people who
have DNA traits that
create scenarios that are
easy to see from far away.
I'm outta here.
Iris, see ya.